[Music]
it's
God it's
God so that's another Muslim that got
cooked and baked and boiled who's next
Jesus Jesus prostrated how do you know
that so I think I think that's widely
accepted by Christians and by Muslims
that Jesus prostrated you know there's
practices practices of the early church
prostration uh and in Islam obviously
you know they prostrate in their prayers
so therefore the uh obviously they got
this from Muhammad
right um but from what the Islamic
standpoint is um there's no I don't I
don't see too much of a clear link but
the prophets it's a succession of
prophets right howy how do you know Max
how do you know that Jesus
prostrated how do I know that Jesus
frustrated
yeah uh I believe there's verses in the
Bible that um that cover that the so the
Bible is what tells you how Jesus
practiced his religion
right uh yes okay so when Jesus
prostrated who did he prostrate to
specifically what did he call
him the father beautiful is Allah the
father of
Jesus is Allah the father of
Jesus
def let let him answer is Allah the
father of Jesus man so I mean God is the
father of
Jesus then you're not a
Muslim no it depends on what you mean by
father depends on what you mean by
father you're not you're not a Muslim if
you say that that God is the father of
Jesus uh Max because the Quran is very
clear and emphatic about those who say
Jesus is the son of
God you know it says that God's Allah's
curse is upon them and he is against
those who say such
things you get what I'm saying I get
what you're saying yeah so that would
mean if if Jes if God is the father of
Jesus and that's what Jesus is teaching
then that shows that he's not a Muslim
you feel what I'm saying yeah that makes
sense yep so that's my whole point bro
Jesus ain't a Muslim can't
be and I will prove that Islam was false
then so what if we can prove that the
Bible is not a reliable source of
information would that negate
it what language did Jesus speak Adam I
don't know what language he spoke where
did Jesus live Adam that's an easy one
man come on that
easy I don't know he does it doesn't
matter doesn't change say that again
spoke aric oh see Max said he Max knows
the answer I want to know for me it
doesn't matter cuz Allah didn't mention
the Quran he spoke he spoke Aramaic
which is it's closer to Arabic than you
know for example English is closer to
Arabic now let's be clear here let's be
clear here Max you're still a Muslim
right am I still a
Muslim I cannot say I am praise God bro
praise the mighty name of
Jesus it's because he's the truth of the
goel we have a Muslim in the chat by the
name maybe you can highlight his name
brother God logic Adel says at God logic
apologetics I'm leaving Islam thank you
rob Avery and wish you all the best
Basher it's me Adel shh who is on the
panel that's all I want to say so oh wow
because of this live show he left
Islam come hold on I'll make room for
you this propaganda is not working
anymore
shut shut up while we while we uh praise
God while somebody came out of your dark
fake Pagan religion what's up
bro yes I want to say thank
you did you leave Islam you said yeah
it's too overwhelming you know
like I've been following Islam for all
my
life
yes what guy attention to leave Islam if
you don't mind us asking obviously like
what made you like what was the main
points I mean all of it I'm following
every for a long
time beautiful wow wow we're happy for
you my friend to be honest everything is
nonsense in Islam yeah I found out and
we agree with you brother all of it all
of it it's not a specific thing but all
of it
wow praise God brother praise God for
you you've been you're seeing the truth
seeing the light Rob go ahead yeah so
what
about what about praying with us right
now L sh hold on we're gonna remove her
Satan thean from the panel yeah she's
manifesting so ADH now that you left
Islam brother can we invite you to
Christianity and pray with us to accept
Christ in your life as your lord and
savior amen right now I
what do you say can you raise up can you
raise up your
voice like right now I too
overwhelmed like I don't want to join
any other religion right now because all
my life i' I've been living a lie you
know like I'm literally shaking right
now yeah it's too hard I know I totally
understand but especially uh especially
being a Muslim and leaving Islam is too
hard and we totally understand that
brother we'll definitely keep you in our
prayers everybody please and the
audience keep the brother in you guys'
prayers and I highly suggest you brother
you know listen to God's Logic yeah
listen to God logic like how he preaches
about Christianity and and gives his uh
teachings as well you know you got Sam
sham on he's another brother you know in
Christ amazing brother that actually
teaches really good regarding
Christianity and I obviously highly
recommend you to open the Bible and read
uh start with Gospel of John brother can
you all pray for me right now yes we can
of course
yeah go ahead God logic or anybody
s yeah go ahead and pray for him father
God we thank you first of all we thank
you for your goodness we thank you for
your grace we thank you for your
kindness we thank you for your mercy we
thank you for your son who by the power
of the Holy Spirit brings those who hear
your voice out of the darkness we thank
you you for chasing after the one sheep
who was lost and we thank you Lord God
for holding on tightly to them revealing
yourself to them bringing them out of
darkness and revealing them to your
Marvelous Light Lord God we appreciate
you we ask God that you protect adal we
ask that you place your hand upon him
send him your spirit Lord God to walk
with him daily to be in his ear to be in
his sleeps to be in his dreams so that
he is overcome by your grace overcome by
love to where he now is running after
you you have brought him out of the lies
of Islam you brought him out of the
darkness of Islam and now Lord God he is
in the space where he can be open to you
and to hearing your voice hearing the
gospel of your son who came down in the
in the flesh for a deal for me for all
of us sinners to die on the cross and
rise again for us so that we're not
stained by our sin anymore but we come
and we are resurrected into New Life In
You Lord God ask that you reveal
yourself to adal bring him home to you
Lord God bless him protect him cherish
him and show him why it is that you are
the true God show up to him Lord God
when he calls out to you make yourself
known to him make your presence known to
where there's no way in the world he can
deny that it's you in Jesus mighty name
we pray amen amen beautiful uh by the
way Adil you know we know we know how
hard it is for any Muslim to leave Islam
so my I salute you my friend I'm really
happy for you and I have I have much
respect for any Muslim who when he sees
everything in on the screen presented to
him from his books that he has no other
choice but to leave Islam so my brother
uh Rome was not built in one day uh we
we pray for you the whole chat is
praying for you everybody who's
listening is praying for you so brother
take your time we know it's very hard
heart take your time Rome wasn't built
in one day then when you have time when
you you you know you you fix your stuff
start read the Bible and pray to Christ
pray to Christ pray to Jesus Christ tell
him ask him if you are truly who you
said you are please guide me to the
truth show yourself to me and guide me
back home so brother pray tonight or
pray tomorrow whenever you you know you
think you're ready pray to him and ask
him to help you in your life and you
will see clearly that Jesus had a plan
for you today my friend God bless you
stay safe we know the consequences of
any Muslim who leaves Islam under sharw
we know the capital punishment so stay
safe and be blessed in the Name of
Christ the true Living God God bless you
I want to say something to
bash yes go ahead go ahead adal make
sure you speak up louder so that he can
hear you too we want to hear come closer
to the mic
now yeah yeah it's better yeah bash so
the sooner you will find out I I know
you are you are honestly answering every
questions and I was I joined live
yesterday also and the sooner you will
find out and leave Islam the better it
will be for you that's all I want to say
Amen you are young I know
yeah that's it guys thank you thank you
hope to hope to hear from you soon
brother yeah all right take
[Music]
care oh my godic